hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on 400 again and
today's gonna be a little bit of a
remake video from the original one about
a year ago if you're
totally confused on what's going on
pretty much in the last video which if
you want to see the full video based on
that it'll be in the eye in the top
right as well at the end of this video
if you want to be if you want to watch
the entire video to be completely up to
date what's going on
but because the year 4 season 2 has been
delayed they're going to be giving us a
lot of old content back for may
and it's going to be all four events
from year three on a weekly basis
and today is going to be the black
priors for pasta event for the next week
so i'm basically gonna be making a
remake of the original video from a year
ago for the old players who forgot what
was in the event
and for the new players who haven't
played it yet as i know some of you have
entered the game around year four and
have no idea what's going on
and some of the things have changed and
some have stayed so we're going to be
going through
that as well in today's video so as
always i'd like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new i cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hear
updates the patch notes of the leaks if
you're going to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely
subscribe to the channel and with that
let's get started with today's video so
first up like i said we're going to be
going over the content that is currently
present in the remake as i'm going to be
calling it for the rest of this video
and the future videos to come
this being the black priors for past
event remake and then after that we're
going to be going over what was in the
original but didn't make it to the part
2 remake version so in terms of the
content that is coming with this event
we're going to be seeing the main menu
screen coming back for the week it's
gonna be this red blood moon kind of
style it's still pretty present
on top of that the minions from the
event are also still present as well
lots of different styles for these guys
like we get every event i believe from
left to right it is
knights samurai and vikings i believe
not some crazy news but it's still cool
that it's getting a change
and i still think the samurai is the
best one returning is also the weapons
from the event which is this nice
realistic
silver style on the weapons and as
always i have the weapons in order
and it's going to be aramusha in the top
left berserker in the top right bp
bottom left and centurion on the bottom
right
next is conqueror gladiator highlander
and jj
with kensei lawbringer nobushi and nusha
to follow
orochi raider shaman and peacekeeper are
up next
second last is shaolin tiandi shinobi
and shugoki
with the last three being warden warlord
and valkyrie if i went a little bit too
fast you can always pause the video at
your leisure
now do remember though that since this
was the black prior event
that means bp was kind of the main
character through the season
meaning hito kiri yorman gunder and zhan
hu were not released this time and not
even mentioned at this point
meaning you cannot get the weapons for
these three characters as they never had
weapons in this event to begin with so
you'll get weapons for every single
character in the game like normal
but if you do play hito kiri yorman
gunder and zhang hu
there will be no weapons so if you're
trying to grind weapons for those three
you can't because there is none this is
going to be changing on a
weekly basis of course because the
events are changing weekly and i'll be
covering those in the future videos as
to not
confuse everyone and go over it now so
just wait for next week and it'll change
up just a slight bit
there's also going to be a lot more
cosmetic items added to the game that
are returning
the effects the emotes etc there is a
lootable mood effect called the
vordiger's dark oath available in
execution idol and emote and if you're a
new player or if you don't remember how
this stuff works with events
remember that when you do loot something
at the end game screen it could say
something
like nusha effect that doesn't mean that
it's for all three it could be the idle
the execution or the emotes meaning you
have to get all three of them
for the character if you want to fully
complete the set obviously if you just
want only the execution then all you
need to do is hope
it's the execution one and these are
completely randomized then we'll recap
that later in the video there's also the
battle outfit on the left as you're
seeing with the faction specific
ornament called the vortices hawk which
are both lootable and
faction specific meaning it is the same
ornament but it changes slightly
depending on which faction
has that ornament with them as you can
tell by the picture there's a few slight
differences between some of the factions
but the overall general concept is the
same
there's also the embossings available
for each character if you want to get
those two
and then also is the emote called
vordiger's ascent for 10 000 steel this
event also released four mask outfits
for each of the factions but
they're gonna be like different kinds of
birds perfection but seeing as they were
still in the game after the event
you could have picked these up at any
time you want for 20 000 steel these are
definitely not going away so
you can either get it this week next
week next month or next year
doesn't matter as these won't be going
anytime soon now to go over what is
lootable that is the effect the ornament
the embossing and the battle outfit of
course the effect being an emote idol
and execution just based on dumb luck
and obviously the weapons are also
lootable too but that's its own little
section in two seconds we'll explain
but yeah all you have to do is just play
games play arcade play any type of mode
ever and you will be getting these at
the end of the screen so obviously if
you want to have champion status at the
end of the game it'll give you more if
you want to get all of that stuff
as quick as possible the biggest one to
do is arcade but if you don't have
arcade i totally understand
i just have to play regular game modes
and champion status does help with
getting more of these items
purchasable stuff it is the emote and
mask outfit the emote is going to be a
limited time thing so you have to get it
within the week whereas the mask outfits
have been here since
it started a year ago so if you don't
got the 20k steal no worries it'll still
be there
even when this event is gone and then
the weapons are also lootable but as
opposed to it being a random choice you
have to have these specific characters
so if you want the highlander weapons
you gotta play highlander you won't get
any other weapons from the event
from any other character except the one
that you're playing with in that match
so for the ornament embossing battle
offense stuff that's just random you
could get neusha while you're playing
hito kiri whereas with the weapons you
have to pick
the specific character that you want the
specific weapon for which is why i
showed off all of them
currently now that we're done with the
quick recap of things when it comes to
the remake now we can move on to the
other thing which is stuff that wasn't
released in the remake that was in the
original
and the only thing pretty much is the
original gamemode battle of attrition
battle of attrition is this twist on
dominion and harbor it's a standard 1000
points to break the enemy and then once
they break you kill them they don't
spawn just your normal dominion game
with a little bit of a weird twist the
attackers could only get points from
conquering zones and the defenders can
only get points from killing soldiers
and killing players
this has now been changed to hyper duel
a gamemode that has existed for quite a
bit and has come back
every now and then over the past couple
months and it's dual but with multiple
lives and you spawn right away it's a
pretty cool game mode but i'm more of a
4v4 guy myself so i don't really play
this too often the only other two things
that i ha
i didn't mention at the end was a new
arcade quest the jiao no michi
wahebi i don't actually know if that was
part of the black priors event i don't
think it was i think that was maybe
either the hito kiri event
or some other random arcade quest i
don't think this actually belongs to the
black priors or pasta event
and then there's also a warrior
challenge which probably isn't specific
to the game mode at all because usually
events
challenges during an event have to do
with the game mode and seeing as there's
no game mode
it may just have to be like kills or
something like that so no worries on
those two
and yeah that's pretty much the quick
recap of what the remake is going to be
bringing us i plan on doing this every
single week for the hitokiri event the
yorm event and the sunda event i also
will be releasing other videos
throughout that so if you already
understand this stuff and you don't want
to hear me ramble on
for the next month about old content
i'll have a couple videos out that
should hopefully set that aside yeah let
me know what you guys think about this
stuff in the comments down below as
always like the v if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new
i cover the informational side of honor
that being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update
definitely subscribe to the channel like
that take care guys i'll see you guys
actually in a couple days peace out
[Music]
you